back at it
once again
whoo
everybody welcome back let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
welcome back y'all we got a big episode
today
so much to talk about there was a spy
balloon
Kyrie Irving asked for a trade
my Super Bowl prediction
and Netflix is trying to charge us
when we sharing passwords so we're gonna
talk about that plus Comics plus news
and notes but once again welcome back
[Music]
you won't know
yeah
[Music]
am I the only podcaster doing the
podcast live doing the theme song live
as usual welcome to riffin with Griffin
live every week unless I have a guest
ah some water welcome we're from
griffinairgriffin.com
uh thanks for being here everybody
thanks for subscribing so please
subscribe share like hit the
notifications so you know when I'm going
live and all that kind of stuff and as
you know if you know me I'm Eric Griffin
gaming I have videos on YouTube Griffin
gaming but I'm live on Twitch most days
I'll be live on Twitch after this if you
want to support the show you could be a
subscriber on Twitch you could be a
YouTube member or you can even join the
patreon if you just want to support uh
and help me grow to keep keep doing the
show really if you enjoy this show and
what I do so I appreciate you guys for
uh being here every single week
so thank you so much and oh uh today's
Tuesday so hey New York guess what New
York New York New York coming your way
to the Bell House February 10th this
Friday in Brooklyn so please get your
tickets now go to ericgriffin.com you go
to my Instagram or go to the link there
and you can find the tickets at Bell
house or just search for Bell House New
York in Brooklyn one night one show come
see me y'all spread the word if you're
in the New York area and I will be there
you know I gotta show these people that
I can sell these tickets so if you
really want to come see me in your New
York come on let's make the push right
now this week see you there see you
there
see all right y'all Where Brooklyn at
and uh before we start that let's do a
little business we got a little do a
little business I want to thank the
sponsor of our show door Dash everybody
doordash
server from doordash
spend more time doing what you love get
50 off up to 20 value at zero delivery
fees when you download the doordash app
and enter code Griffin
also a fantastic sponsor of the show is
DraftKings DraftKings sports book
download draftking Sportsbook app and
use code riffin
you hear me use code riffin only at
draftkingsports book with code Roofing
get a five dollar bet at a Super Bowl 57
and get 200 in bonus
bets instantly minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply void in
Ohio see show notes for details
all right what's up y'all what's up
y'all what's up y'all hello chat hello
everybody that's here live thank you for
being here at another episode of riffin
with Griffin I want to thank everybody
that comments all the time got some
great comments on here uh you know let's
see what we got here uh Mario Jimenez uh
he said I work with James Gunn on his
first superhero movie super super
starring rain Wilson he was cool and fun
to work with it's awesome to see how
he's revolutionized the comic and
Cinematic Universe so there's somebody
that's a huge fan of the James Gunn I
talked about it last week so thanks uh
for that
um uh who's this one
dulio Roldan I don't know if I'm saying
your name right I'm terrible with names
he says great podcast I'm I'm that that
I am one that doesn't really like
American football but the way you
explain it and speak on it I oddly like
it
weird comment but I appreciate that
thank you so much for that comment uh
let's see oh then I have somebody that's
anti-eagles uh Ernie hildalgo Eric the
Eagles are really bad team with the
easiest schedule all year a hurt my
homes will destroy the Eagles in the
Super Bowl it's going to be an absolute
blowout and it's going to be such a
boring Super Bowl that's what he thinks
yeah I don't know if I necessarily agree
with that
um
John Aquarius uh sent a message I still
think DC Warner Brothers is making a
mistake and I'm not crazy about any of
their announcements ooh that was
something I talked about last week with
all the DC's making their announcements
about stuff and plenty of other really
great Comics I appreciate you guys
commenting
um you know you guys got weird names
you know but uh you know it is what it
is
here's another Diana Williams I truly
appreciate your NFL talk keeps me cool
with my grown sons
I like that that's cool so anyways
thanks for being here guys uh you know I
guess I'm tipping something if you watch
golden hour you know you're gonna if you
watch this and you watch golden hour oh
Isn't that cool how the my shirt is like
blue so it's like it looks like the
stars are on my chest there
anyways
um thanks everybody that listens too so
if you're listening on whatever you
listen on thanks for listening to me
every single week I appreciate you and
you know
that that's very thoughtful actually I
should go look check out those comments
too I'll do that next week look at some
of those comments on the audio and it
also helps me out you know go go give me
five stars and comment on the audio so
more people listen to that helps with
the algorithm and all that kind of stuff
uh appreciate you guys in the chat who
are chatting live right now
um
so thank you for being here I appreciate
you guys uh yeah somebody in the chat
last of us has been amazing I know I've
been watching Last of Us I've been
talking about it it is pretty good it's
up and down though you know it's up and
down like uh but it very much reminds me
of Walking Dead in the beginning years
because it's like you know you're gonna
have one episode you might meet some
characters and you're like oh I really
like that and then the next episode it's
just more stuff to explain the overall
overall Arc of the season so some of
that stuff might not be that exciting
but you know Pascal's a great actor the
girl's good and it's just like they're
really they have good chemistry so
Following the show is actually you know
it's pretty good you know you know what
I mean so but is up and downs and we'll
see how it all ends out in the uh in the
end you know what I mean and yeah yeah I
agree with uh whatever splashy whatever
how you say the name drop a like guys
hit me with a like on this likes help
you like right now it's gonna help
YouTube Go oh people like this and then
I'll tell more people and then more
people will come watch the show
um
yeah so anyways welcome back
I actually got a lot to talk about today
you know I got a lot to talk about today
so let's just get right into it all
right let us get right into everything
that I have to talk about today so I
just want to get to the where is it oh
here we go
right from the thumbnail first thing I
want to talk about right now is this big
story about
uh you know Kyrie Irving
Kyrie Irving asked for a trade from the
from the Brooklyn Nets y'all Kyrie
Irving gone he's now with the Dallas
Mavericks so this is like a week old
spent a lot of conversation to talk on
first take on ESPN Stephen A Smith and
Jay Williams they had a big fight about
this there you know Stephen A Smith has
been talking a lot about Kyrie Irving
for like two three years
um is he hard on I think he's I think
he's been fair in my opinion Stephen A
Smith has been fair to Kyrie Irving
because Kyrie Irving has been just like
a roller coaster okay it's a roller
coaster so when it's all said and done
the Nets experiment was a colossal
failure
it was probably one of the biggest
failures in NBA history in terms of
putting a team together and seeing if
they can win
um you know up there with let's say
let's just go Seasons so each one of
these seasons was a failure for the Nets
so if you had to go by season if I had
to pick failure seasons in NBA history
I think that
the Lakers team that has Shaq Kobe Carl
Malone and Gary Payton they didn't win a
championship but that's that was the end
of the Lakers dynasty of Kobe Shack they
should have got their stuff together and
I think that would have been a great
Championship to win I wanted to see Carl
Malone get a championship eventually
Gary Payton got one with uh Miami but
it's just that was a big failure season
all right I think that the first uh
Miami LeBron Wade and Bosch that that
was a failure season that was a big
letdown Greg Dallas won but Miami lost
that
you know and then you got this
this net every single one of these
things so that was a big colossal
failure so you know Kyrie Irving he's
had a tumultuous career you know going
back to all the things that he's done
you know when he was with Cleveland he'd
want to be with LeBron anymore and then
he went to Boston and then they were
better without him and then he was like
I'm coming back and he didn't come back
they eventually traded him you know then
you got the Nets and then the Nets you
know he didn't want to play in the
bubble he didn't want to get vaccinated
he went to a party he uh you know didn't
want to play because of some racial you
know the thing that would have what a
another player called in the n-word you
know and he was like I don't want to
play he and you know he went to his
sister's party he he didn't want to play
because of January 6. he uh you know
it's just then he he tweets out the
anti-semitic movie you know Kyrie Irving
has just been a lot on top of that he's
always injured so on top of all that
stuff off the court stuff
he's only played about he's missed over
30 percent of all of his games he could
have played with the Nets it was a
complete and utter failure all right
what do I want to talk about with this
I'll tell you there are three kinds of
basketball I'm going to talk about three
particular types of fans
the first fan is a basketball fan an NBA
fan uh these are usually older people
it's usually people who say things like
I like players to play the right way
they don't like a lot of player movement
uh they you know they want the the GM to
be the one to trade people you know they
want they want guys who want to stay in
the city and be in a team for you know
they want competition they want they
want us they want to see teams you know
these kind of people didn't like when
Kevin Durant went to Golden State uh you
know these are the type of people that
like like when players give up salaries
so other people can get paid so the team
can be good and the league can flourish
you have that kind of fan right the
basketball fan the NBA fan first then
you have the team fan
you have the guy like you know you love
your team you don't care everybody else
is trash unless they on your team and
when the guy that you've been trashing
for years he finally comes to your team
you're like yeah I'm glad we have him my
team first all you care about is your
team
the last fan is
the player fan the Kyrie Irving fan
you're a fan of Kyrie Irving you think
he's been shafted you love his movies
you love that he stands up for things
you love that he has a man of integrity
you love that he gives to charity all
right so I'm gonna talk about these
three types of fans in in terms of
what's going on with this Kyrie Irving
situation all right first thing like I
said
NBA and then where are you guys in it so
if you had a pie chart and you had to
pick three of these things what is the
percentage you are of these three types
of fans let me know
are you like 50 NBA fan 10 Kyrie Irving
fan and then the rest 40 you are you
know a fan of the team or what do you
think your thing is and you know let me
know what you guys think of that or tell
me the order of importance for you give
me your thoughts Okay so
I'm gonna try to talk about it and try
not to be biased I if I had to think of
these things for me my percentage I'm
more of an NBA fan overall I'm one of
those people I'm an old head I like play
the right way defense wins championships
I'm not for all this player I don't like
the the player empowerment to me isn't
necessarily what's best for the league
and these players they're always talking
about and it's always the rich ones too
by the way it's always dudes making 25
plus million dollars a year who say
stuff like I just want to do what's best
for my family you making 25
30 million dollars a year you could live
in Milwaukee Minnesota or whatever until
you're 35 and then you can do whatever
the rest you want to do with your life
and your family with the 100 and so
million dollars you have in the bank but
for the sake of the league it's better
that you are playing that we have some
competition that there's competition
that players are fighting with each
other and building rivalries and and
building establishing that you're this
is my city my team I'm playing for I
think that's better that's just my
opinion that's I just think you know you
could disagree and it's totally okay you
know what I mean but I just feel like
you know I don't like the little LeBron
James has gone all over the place and
everything that he's done I don't like
it like it I didn't like when he went to
Miami I didn't like it I think he should
have stayed in Cleveland and tried to
make it work but In fairness to him he
gave him seven years when his contract
was up then he decided to move if he
gonna do it I like to me you do it that
way right but I like defense I like uh I
like the when the league as a whole
flourishes so when I see this happened
when I I didn't like any of it going
back to Kevin Durant leaving Oklahoma
City and going to the Warriors
I've just been on the league I really
have I think it was a black mark on the
league in my opinion uh you know he goes
over there changes the balances of power
it looked like it was going to be this
great rivalry of Oklahoma City and
golden state fighting to see who goes to
the championship every year we would
have loved that we would have loved it
okay ah never happened he goes to Golden
State you're talking about one of the
top three best players in the league
right whatever team he would have went
to he would have been the best player
this argument that oh those
championships count just as much he was
the best player no matter where he would
have gone he would have been the best
player if Jordan would have went to the
Celtics in the 80s he would have been
the best player if Jordan would have
went to the Lakers and played with magic
worthy Kareem or whoever was still left
when uh I don't know if Kareem was still
playing at the time he would have been
the best player if Jordan would have
went to the Utah Jazz and played with
stocked in him alone he would have been
the best player so what that doesn't
mean it makes it better that's the
reason to me makes it worse you know
what I mean it makes it worse but
anyways he went he won his championships
he got a lot of flack once again he had
an issue with people he was working with
like he didn't like Russell Westbrook
they didn't work out he moved
he he won championships but then it
started to not work out he moved he got
James Harden to leave Houston come it
didn't work out James Harden moved now
Kyrie Irving moved you know I'd already
told you about all the Kyrie Irving
stuff I think all of this has been for
the league sucks and I'm not a big I'm
not as a biggest fan of the NBA anymore
because of it like I literally stopped
watching I don't watch it as much
anymore for two reasons the pandemic
after that when the pandemic I just
pre-prioritized I used to have Clipper
tickets guys I love the Clippers I used
to go to Clipper games all the time I
literally have not watched the NBA at
that much at all this year because I
just haven't been interested with the
with the you know Kawhi Leonard coming
in and out of the lineup people being
hurt this load management uh you know I
just don't feel I don't feel good about
the NBA right now I'm kind of like down
on it so this in terms of this Kyrie
Irving situation as I look at it as a
fan of the NBA I'm a little down so I
don't like it all right number two fan
you're a fan of your team all right if
you're a Nets fan you were down the dude
was playing great Kyrie Irving was
27-5 and whatever his stats are it's
only six or seven players in the league
doing as good as he's doing all that
stuff that happened off the court he was
like all right I gotta get my money I
gotta get my bag so he's been playing
good playing great playing phenomenal
all he's leading the league in All-Star
votes for guards in the East that should
tell you something right there about how
great Kyrie Irving is playing and what
people feel about him
so if you're a fan of the team
right now you hate them if you're a Nets
you're like man why are you leaving us
but if you're a Dallas Maverick fan
you're like Bring It On
bring it on if you're a Dallas fan
and even if you're a fan of the NBA and
you're that's you like this right the
NBA people too are like oh okay now we
got Luca got somebody to help him Luca
he he's got a lot of usage he holds the
ball a lot but he tires out at the end
of games and in bat in series he always
later in the series he starts to like oh
he's looking because he needs to get in
better shape in my opinion but anyways
Kyrie Irving is going to come and help
we'll see how that looks Kyrie Irving
knows how to play with a superstar he's
done it twice now and shined right he
could do it so let's see I don't even
think it's Kyrie Irving that has to
change his game it's actually Luka
dances he got to change his name change
his game he can't be dribbling the ball
all the time and be like you gotta you
gotta first of all you gotta do it on
the wing who's
just as good as you and is more
accomplished the dude over here on the
wing now got a championship homie he got
a championship okay so you pass him the
ball and watch him go to work too so
that's going to be interesting can they
work but if you're a Dallas Mavericks
fan you're like yeah this is great bring
him on we're in Texas we don't care
about vaccines you know what I mean
they're gonna be like you we love you
man we support everything you did we
you're our guy now so if you're a Dallas
Maverick fan this has got to be a great
day for you a great week because you got
a dude that's gonna help your guy and
let's all remember they were in the
Western Conference finals last year
Western Conference Finals
crazy right okay
so
what's next
um
oh now
let's talk about this the last fan
you're a Kyrie Irving fan
now In fairness to Kyrie Irving
I'm not a fan of like all the Antics
like I say I think it's I think it just
doesn't shine well in the league but if
you are a Kyrie Irving fan you love
Kyrie Irving you love Uncle Drew you
love that he's philanthropic this guy
gives a lot of money away man he he give
he's he tries to be thoughtful he tries
to like fight for the the small guy you
know his reasons why he didn't want to
get vaccinated I can respect that you
know I thought some of the some of the
rules were ridiculous and it's turning
out that he was right right you know
what I mean it's turning out that they
made him they they they could have
possibly made a mistake and how they
dealt with it is what I'm really saying
you know what I mean so maybe you're
with him on that uh you love his game if
you're a Kyrie Irving fan you're like
this dude's great you're like LeBron
couldn't have won without Kyrie you
remember that he hit the shot to win the
championship you know you know what I
mean they put him in the lead and then
LeBron's block shot sealed it but you
got to remember that this dude it pow
and deed up uh Steph Curry Steph Curry
didn't score for the last four minutes
of that game and turned the ball over a
couple times Kyrie Irving was on him so
you go you're a Kyrie Irving fan some of
his off court stuff you go hey man it is
what it is he went to his sister's party
who cares you know he didn't want to do
that it shouldn't be such a big deal
even with this movie thing you're just
like all right he put that out I don't I
I believe him when he says he's not
anti-semitic maybe the other message is
in the movie he was like I support that
and maybe he didn't realize how bad it
was and how people are going to respond
and he's like look if it's so bad why is
it being offered see you're a person
that's looking at that like well why is
it on Amazon if it's so bad why aren't
people getting on that guy right and
then if you're a Kyrie Irving fan you're
like why did they have all these
ridiculous stipulations for him to come
back I didn't agree with none of that
stuff it shouldn't have been so hard for
him to come back and then now the Seal
of it is I'm actually on Kyrie Irving
side get your money the dude's 30.
this is gonna be his last big contract
okay
most likely this is going to be his last
big contract so he's like yo hey Nets
give me a contract and they're like okay
we'll give you a contract but they had
all these ridiculous stipulations for
him to get his money he was like all
right bye because I could just leave at
the end of the year anyway he's like nah
let me go I don't want to be with I
don't even want to be here anymore I
don't like y'all you don't like me I'm
out
this is it right there so there it is so
if you're a fan of Kyrie Irving all that
stuff is in your you know in your
Stratosphere and you're like you know
what
let's go we're with you dude so I think
there's three or four different types of
fans me personally like I said I'm more
of an NBA fan I want to see the NBA
shine and be good I like competition I
like seeing teams I don't like knowing
that this is the one best team and then
like you know because they just
constructed in the off season they got
all the best players and now nobody can
beat them I don't like that but I do
like a team that builds up drafts well
maybe they get a trade or two and here
they are and you're like oh wow here's
this great team and everybody tries to
beat them I think that's great you know
but it's just like what has been
happening in the NBA right now I don't
like it but if you're a fan of Dallas
and you I feel you you know if you're a
fan of Kyrie Irving I also feel you so
it is what it is
anyways that's my Kyrie Irving talk
didn't mean to go that long with it I
just love that stuff
um before we before we go on with that
let's now get a word from our great
sponsors of this show doordash doordash
I use doordash I love doordash because
it don't they don't just do it's not
just like getting food
delivered
that's the great thing about it it's not
just getting food delivered and once
again let me just say thank you to our
sponsor doordash
um you know you know what you know when
you need to get groceries you need to
get like household items that's what's
great about these things too because
sometimes you forget stuff and you're
like oh man I need like this this and
this because I'm trying to make
something boom you hit up doordash or
it's like all your favorite restaurants
in the area you there's some great
restaurants in the area that maybe you
don't want to go out or maybe you just
want to your homebody or maybe you've
been busy or maybe you just like I say
you just don't you want to be in the
comfort of your home in front of your TV
you order some doordash and it comes
you know what I mean so
dining hall food can only satisfy you so
many Cravings y'all so for the night you
absolutely need some Chinese food or
some mozzarella sticks from your
favorite off-campus pizza joint use door
Dash with zero delivery fees exclusive
items and more than 25 000 member only
offers Nationwide get your dash pass by
doordash it has everything you need to
make this semester memorable for all you
back to school people or save even more
with five percent doordash credits
back on pickup orders Dash pasture
students gives you access to more than
just your favorite restaurants saving
you grocery runs convenience store trips
and even you know
shopping for gifts it's great for a
limited time our listeners get 50 off
and up to 20 value whoa dude
our listeners get 50 off and up to 20
value up to a twenty dollar value and
zero delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter code refin that's
riffin that's 50 off and up to 20 value
and zero delivery fees when you download
the doordash app and the App Store and
enter code within don't forget that's
code riffin for 50 off and up to twenty
dollar value and zero delivery fees with
doordash subject to change terms apply
DraftKings Super Bowl is coming I'm
gonna be using the app because I'm going
to Vegas I look I go to Vegas every year
for the Super Bowl and I love it
uh DraftKings Sports and official sports
betting partner of the Super Bowl 57 and
it has all the Super Bowl action that
you need this is gonna be such an
outstanding game I can't wait I'm gonna
talk about it after this but check the
drafting Sports app every day between 6
p.m and 9 00 p.m and 3 P.M to 6 p.m
Pacific to see what prop bets will be
boosted new customers can be just can
bet just five dollars and get 200 and
bonus bets instantly you hear that
instantly so let's do it download the
DraftKings Sports app and use code
riffin new customers can bet up to five
dollars on Super Bowl 57 and get 200 in
bonus bets instantly only at DraftKings
Sportsbook with code Griffin minimum age
eligibility restriction Supply voted
void in Ohio see show notes for details
anyways man
take care of business there all right
guys
um again thanks for being here Daddy
gotta pay the bills
all right so let's go to now
our Super Bowl preview
Super Bowl prediction I'm saying it's
time and next I come back on the Super
Bowl would have been done and whatever's
gonna happen so as you see from the chat
there's a lot of people that think uh oh
you know what let me put a poll up a lot
of people think that some people think
they know the Eagles are gonna
the beagles are going to do it all right
so let's do this let me I'm gonna put a
poll up in the chat Super Bowl winner
okay Chiefs
let me spell it right Chiefs
Eagles what you got y'all what you got
so let me tell you how I feel about it I
think these are two great teams I think
the Eagles are all-time great team in
terms of the talent that they have
on the team that offensive line that
defensive line the secondary the
linebackers and then they got this uh
talented quarterback he can run he could
pass he's a leader people love him the
people his teammates love him so the
eagles look like a really daunting task
for someone to beat now leading up to
this game Jalen Hurst hasn't actually
had the best games but that happens you
know you're getting your best from
people you're getting their best uh you
know these are playoff teams it's hard
to make it to the Super Bowl but he
hasn't necessarily shown that he's
Top Flight quarterback yet he just got a
really Top Flight team but we'll see
what happens then on the other side you
got Chiefs you got this all-time great
already
I think you could put Patrick Mahomes in
the top five quarterbacks of all time
already five straight AFC championships
this would be his third Super Bowl he's
got one win
this is a this you know he's probably
gonna be 100 after getting two weeks off
this is an exciting game the dude's
spectacular he's got a good team around
him too they don't necessarily have the
same kind of pieces as the other side of
the ball you know the other team
especially on offense you know he's got
Travis Kelsey and then he's got some man
some good players
so we'll see
what do I think is going to happen
what do I think is gonna happen
um yeah like you say you know uh well
you you're not counting last year's
games too he's you know 16-1 this year
as a starter but you know he also had
some games last year but anyways and he
lost in the playoffs last year so um
yeah Jalen hurts is a great quarterback
I mean he was in before he got hurt he
was going to be the MVP he was he was
leading leading MVP person was
jalenhurst so let me not act like I
don't think he's great I'm just saying
he didn't have the he hasn't had the
greatest games yet in the playoffs we'll
see and remember that's kind of a knock
on him from his Alabama days let's not
forget that but anyways I think the
Eagles are better all-around team
I didn't pick either one of these teams
to go to the Super Bowl I actually
thought Cincinnati was going to go to
the Super Bowl and they were going to
play the 49ers and Cincinnati was going
to win so I was completely wrong about
that so take everything I say with a
grain of salt
but I'll say this I am
when I go and make my bet I'm a bet on
the Chiefs I'm a bet on the Chiefs to
cover whatever that means so like by the
way last year I won but I bet on
Cincinnati last year
and they covered I bet on Cincinnati to
cover
oh no
and
I think we're back
yes and we're back
man the Eagles players sent a virus or
something
oh man I don't know what happened there
but lost connection uh
so that's weird but anyways sorry about
that that's what happens when you do
stuff live so I'm probably gonna have to
like download this episode and then
re-re upload it without that little
little thing but anyways
um we're here thanks for being here
sorry for the that little delay right
there
um
so I do think that it's gonna be the
Chiefs
I think the Chiefs are gonna win so
that's what I feel about the Super Bowl
I don't know what you guys think
sorry about that guys for the I had
connection issues and for the people
that are listening and it was like a
weird pause or whatever this like that
I'm gonna I'll probably edit you
probably didn't even hear about it
because I probably edited for the for
the audio side but the video side it is
what it is I think this video is still
going to be one complete video but I
think a lot oh look at this let's look
at the poll right now right now it's 57
Chiefs 43 Eagles um
so I think the Chiefs are going to win
um for the people asking let me say it
again I just feel like Patrick Mahomes
is on a mission and I think he's gonna
will his team to Victory I think he's
gonna spread that ball around because
he's gonna have to I think he's gonna
use his legs I think Travis Kelsey is
gonna just show up in big moments I
think that run game is going to do their
job and I just feel like uh and I think
their defense is is pretty good it's
solid they got a solid enough defense I
think they're gonna Force
jalenhurst to to pass and then we'll see
if that'll be successful but they got
some great receivers over there so
Brown and uh what's his name uh Smith is
it Smith what's that other guy what's
that other receiver's name on Eagles
I think it is Smith right so anyways
they're two number one receivers over
there so we'll see if
the Chiefs can hold the run because
uh Eagles love to run they run great and
they and Jalen Hurst anchors that so
well yeah it is Smith Devonte Smith yeah
that's what I thought so we'll see what
happens with
this Super Bowl game
looks like it's almost even there uh
cheap you know on the pole on our
YouTube poll
Super Bowl winner 56 looks like people
are saying
it's gonna be Chiefs so you guys agree
with me then a lot of I think the
majority of you are saying you think the
Chiefs are going to win
uh but we'll see man we'll see you know
I I actually am not going to be
surprised if that Eagles defense which
is an all-time defense holds up you know
they have the third most sacks as a team
in a season in in NFL history that's
hard to do so they're gonna be going
after him and if you remember
I just want to point this out too I
think Patrick Mahomes is great I think
he's all-time great I think he's already
had a Hall of Fame career but in that
first Super Bowl he only had one good
quarter like they were down 10. all
right and he he got him back but he
wasn't playing all that great and let's
not forget how the Tampa Bay defense put
it on them man
with hurt offensive line he was running
all over the place and he couldn't get
it done so if you look at his numbers in
his two previous Super Bowls it's not
great I think that's on his mind and
he's gonna come out and have a great
Super Bowl so I look for that man
look out for that man
um all right let's let's keep moving on
let us keep moving on
um
I'll talk about that last all right
let's talk about this now guys
Netflix we all got Netflix accounts
you know we all got Netflix accounts I
don't know but we all don't pay for our
Netflix accounts so apparently Netflix
is trying to crack down on
password sharing all right that's their
thing
Netflix has decided they're gonna crack
down on
um and so you know what does that mean
though like I'm wondering you know so
apparently as I look at some of these
articles it's like they're gonna work on
they're going to make sure you're in the
same household every time you log in
there's gonna have to be some sort of
past some kind of code that goes to your
two-factor authentication or they're
just gonna try to find a way to crack
down on people sharing passwords what do
you guys think about that you know so
like the question
so we ended that poems I'm gonna start a
new Poll for the the people that are
here live
um if if net you know Netflix cracks
down
um are you staying or going if you don't
this is the people that don't have
accounts or maybe you're you know if you
don't have an account you're using your
parents account or your roommates or
your friend uh you're gonna stay
or go
okay that's what I want to know you're
going to stay or you're gonna go
um you know
here's I just want to I want to show you
guys something I looked this up so they
have these they have these like websites
so this one website and they were
talking about the Netflix key statistics
Netflix now listen to when you hear this
Netflix generated
31.6 billion
dollars in Revenue in 2022. let me say
that again
Netflix generated
31.6 billion dollars in Revenue in 2026.
and that's a 6.7 increase year on year
what
and you trying to get more money
like
how much do they need
like how much
do they need
14 billion of this Netflix Revenue was
generated just in North America alone
its largest market
I don't even know what to say
Netflix has
220 million subscribers
that's over a billion dollars a month in
Revenue
do you hear that
[Music]
220 million subscribers so that's paid
subscribers worldwide
and they're telling us
hey stop sharing your past even with the
sharing of passwords
with the sharing of passwords Netflix is
making
31.6 billion dollars
I ain't trying to take money out of
nobody's pocket okay so I don't know who
and then you know who knows how much of
that money is spent on making projects
so I get it they but that's what we want
that's what we're paying for we're
saying hey we're gonna give you 31
billion dollars and we want you to make
fantastic content and make a little
money for yourself
that's what we've seen so here's 31
billion dollars from us
please make some really great shows
give us stranger things oh it costs 20
million dollars an episode
I don't give a
you're making 31.6 billion that's your
choice
what you you know
we're paying for Content so we want
content so if the profit you what's the
profit how much money they making I
don't know maybe they're saying we're
not making enough for a lot of money
we're spending then do better
I think the the the
binging is a mistake I think they need
to stop that I think stranger things
should come out
and you have to wait a week
wait a week
and then each week now you can watch two
episodes three episodes four episodes
you know so forth and so on and then it
lives there but I don't think you should
get it all at once that's how you can
like that's where you should save money
save money that way because then you
don't have to worry about coming up with
more content all the time because a lot
of crap is on Netflix let me tell you
have you ever just
perused Netflix and looked up a movie
you know you see these movies and you go
what is this the ones that get me are
these cheesy ass television shows
um have you ever like just one of these
comedies where and then you hear the
it's like old school 80s crowd laughter
because you don't even know if there's
anybody even in there when they record
it
do better that's all
31 billion dollars
is it how much money do they want to
make
how much money do they want to make like
we're okay with waiting too by the way
every great show on HBO we can't binge
it we wait succession Last of Us all the
shows they have on there we wait
Euphoria whatever show they have on HBO
we're not over here like where are they
got our bench no we still we've been
paying 15 a month or whatever you pay
for for HBO we've been doing that for 25
years before Netflix even existed we've
been paying for HBO and it hasn't been
an issue
I think and if I'm looking at this poll
it's like 59 of the people are like yeah
I would go if you're not paying for
Netflix first of all if you're not
already paying for Netflix why would you
start it's not cheap
just go to that ad thing that they want
to do you know they want to like make
people buy you know uh here's six
dollars a month but you have to watch
ads that's fine cheap you know people
that don't want to pay for premium and
4K and all that have it tiered I think
this is a mistake
I think with these kind of numbers out
there and you're you're just like wow so
this isn't enough
you know you kind of go who's
mismanaging this money over at Netflix
isn't that that's what I think of when I
see these numbers and it goes Netflix
has generated 31.6 billion dollars a
year I'm like
that's not enough so what are you doing
with the money
somebody needs to get fired or somebody
needs to like figure out hey let's put
aside
some profit so it's crazy man
Apple thank you Apple TV makes you wait
I'm out Severance is great I like to
serve it I like C there's a you know
there's plenty of great shows on other
networks that make you wait Netflix make
us wait we'll still be there it's
actually going to make it better because
you could at the anticipation and you
really get to know the characters and
you're just like when you binge a show
in three weeks you don't really I don't
think you really take it in as much as
you do when you when you have to wait
and follow along Game of Thrones man uh
House of dragons they make you wait
anyways
Netflix you're making a mistake
chill out on this like making everybody
pay because they won't and then it's
gonna be I would I can't I can't wait to
see that I can't wait to see them be
like oh you can't share passwords and
then the viewership just drops because
here's the thing
they're still gonna make the same amount
of money I think I think that
they'll make the money but then because
they already have 220 million
subscribers so if they have 220 million
subscribers maybe they have 500 million
people watching because people are
sharing whatever they're doing so now
it's just gonna be less people are going
to see their stuff
and then that's what generates people
being like oh maybe I should get it I
don't know
I don't know I just
it's just you know let it let us get
like three people on our account how
about that make it part of the thing you
know
I don't know but according to the poll
56 percent of you say you're gonna go so
a lot of you stay you're gonna stay that
even if you had to pay you'd still you'd
pay you love Netflix I get it I get it
so shout out to them that's one of the
major stories of the week
um last thing I want to talk about is
man you know what you know what what
what was everybody talking about for
like so long it's this Chinese spy
balloon I don't know if it's a spy
balloon was it a spy balloon what are
you you know I was watching I was out in
San Diego and I'm looking at Fox News
came on and Hannity came on and man he
was going in he just was like what's
going on this is terrible you know just
the way he was talking I was like the
people listening to him must be like if
they're ill-informed people who don't
know much about nothing you hear this
guy you would think that we're on the
brink of war or whatever it is you know
I would like to think that they saw this
they knew what was going on and why
cause a panic but there's like a push of
like you should have told everybody it's
like okay I I just don't know where I
stand on that I don't know where you
stand on it but I don't know if if the
people need to know everything you know
it's like you kind of feel like you're
like here's our government officials
we're supposed to trust them to do the
right thing
uh you know and and when it comes to uh
Espionage you know what I mean like
should we know everything should there
be like a news report uh we're spying on
China this week and here's how we're
doing it like the whole idea of is that
no one knows right
this is ballsy though
if this is if this isn't a weather
balloon and this was an actual spy
balloon like damn talk about not giving
a
if this is the plan they said yeah just
you know
put this balloon up and let it fly
across and put it over Montana
like they're not even trying now they're
not even trying like like you if you
were writing a movie
about a country spying on the United
States and you in the writer's room and
somebody was like
okay they here's what happened they sent
a balloon across the ocean and then the
balloon floated across uh you know and
was taking pictures you would be like
that's stupid
come on man that wouldn't happen
that doesn't even make sense why would
we let a balloon float across the entire
that's how you would
that person would be like people would
be clowning that person in the writer's
room like y'all man check out Greg over
here talking about like we would let a
balloon float across the country and not
do anything
huh
[Laughter]
who knows man like this is like it's
like are you scared that's what I want
to know are you scared
are you are you like are you a
conspiracy theorist are you kind of
person that's like you see this thing
and you go oh man is there something
going on we don't know about are you
just kind of like living your life
you're on your tick tocks you're on your
you're watching podcasts you're going to
movies you're going to work and you're
just like well hopefully the government
is doing right you know I don't know
I just don't know
uh you know to me it's like
I think oh I think any sort of like
military action amongst superpowers
would just be the worst possible thing
that could possibly happen because right
now we already have this global economy
China makes the we buy the you
know we we we create entertainment and
whatever and we ship that all over the
world too you know we have a global
economy travel Commerce oil everything
that we share and everything that we
sell everything that it's like like
what's gonna happen you know is everyone
going to get together and just be like
we need to go after them I don't know
what's going to happen I don't know how
to feel I don't know how you feel
um
yeah I mean the fact that there is
something about me that just goes Here's
the the the the the that glass half full
part of me is like oh they saw it they
they're in communication with them this
was
you know an accident
or even if it was some sort of attempt
at whatever I think behind the scenes
they're talking about it you know you'd
like to think that our people are on the
phone with their people like yo bro nice
try with the balloon what the you
know and they're like well my bad you
know and they're just like we're spying
on them they're spying on us but because
we're supposed to I guess I I don't know
you know you look you you know you keep
your enemies close right so
I don't know how you guys felt about it
it was uh you know it was really in the
news like what the hell is that and I'm
still sort of like I'm still just
deciding how I feel about it but I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it in the
comments is this something we should be
super worried about is it something you
were just kind of like I think we caught
them and it's that's gonna be the end of
it or or they're gonna have to be way
better at it or I mean what do you think
you know are you paranoid or not where
are you on the scale you know
but anyways guys
you know riffing with Griffin we hear
every single week
um you know I'm gonna keep doing the
podcast so you know as I
I appreciate you guys being here so like
I say Please Subscribe you know
subscribe share all that stuff hit the
likes hit the notifications I'm live
sometime on Tuesday and depending on
what I'm doing because I also I do the
golden hour look out for agenda Jen
we're coming back gender gen podcast I'm
on the golden hour check us out we got
patreon episode comes on Tuesdays and
most the free episodes comes out on
Fridays so check us out on there I'm on
Twitch I'm on Twitch daily y'all twitch
I'm gonna get on Twitch after this so
make sure you guys come check me out
there you know and if you want to be a
patreon member to support the show you
could do you could you could be a twitch
sub patreon member YouTube member any
which way you want to support me like
that I totally appreciate it uh totally
totally totally so y'all know what and
thanks for dealing with the technical
difficulties today that's just how it
goes you know when you're doing it live
and you have to trust the internet at
all times you know what I mean
but anyways
you know what time it is
it's the rap recap
give me some dab
you might get slapped
when I recap oh oh oh
we got that spy balloon
making us look like a buffoon
it's loony too
but give me some room in Dallas cause
Kyrie coming
on Netflix
trying to get that money
got got
they already got
the money
trying to treat me like a dummy
[Music]
the phone's gonna be home
oh he go take a toll on that defense
thanks for being here
in fear
ah
everybody
see you next week everybody
peace out love y'all thank you
[Music]